Again though, you get to sit next
to the quarterback
Right
First Sam Darnold and now Tony Romo
Yeah. Sorry. That's just what happens.
It's a quarterback thing, man.
You stay over there, host.
Yeah. Thanks a lot. I appreciate it.
- But Sam Darnold, we spent time with him.
- OK
- I said one of the, like, coming out of the draft
one of the pro-player comparisons
I kind of compared him to
was your style of play
I said, "Tony Romo. The way he manipulates the pocket
and can move around and
subtly move and make throws."
So we're interested in just your
thought on him specifically
and then of couse, some of the other rookie
QBs that have jumped out to you.
Without making any glaring statements
-Yeah
-Ooh
But I'm about to
-Yeah
-Yes
I actually think Sam Darnold—is
got a chance to end up—at some point
- Right
- to be the best quarterback
in the National Football League
OK
In the whole league?
In the whole league
I actually think he's the best quarterback
to come out in a while—period
-Kind of glaring statement
-Yeah
So there it is
Yeah, there it is.
Some people just have this
rare ability for
nuance that I say are—feel
You know we talk about
- Feel the tackle creeping up on you and you're
getting ready to throw
and you just move and you don't even know why you moved.
-You don't even know why you moved.
It's just an innate feeling
It's just a subtle gift that
I feel like it — for spatial awareness
in your ability just to sense
and you're—you shuffled two steps
and didn't even know you did it
until you rewatch the deal.
And when I see that—it doesn't come
along that often. When you find it
now it's like, "Ok"
When you have that the ceiling is very high
-You had that, dude.
-Yes. Yeah.
That's why there's a similarity
But he's further along than I am in
a sense that it took me years
to get the base—to be strong and set
where he's coming in like that,
which is more Peyton Manning-ish
than I've seen of anybody coming out
You know, I know it's a pretty
bold statement and stuff but
-I'm willing, based on what I've seen
-Yeah
I feel very confidently — I don't know
if he's going to have a good year this year
But I guarantee you within the next three years,
Sam Darnold is for real
- That's awesome
What was your rookie experience like?
Do you remember that, looking back?
Jeez
Yeah, it's a little different probably
than what you guys are doing
-Oh man, Bill Parcells.
-No one actually knew me in the media.
-Yeah, right.
-No one cared about who I was.
Jerry [Jones] learned my name in year four or three
-I think — Parcells was my coach and
-Yes
You were told to be quiet, get in a room,
listen to what I say.
- And shut up
One day, it was rookie year and I was like—
I wanted to impress Coach
and I was
He's like, "We're doing the wet ball drill today."
And he's like, "We're going to dump the ball
in here. I want you guys all wearing gloves."
It was me, Quincy Carter, Chad Hutchinson
Oh my gosh
And he's like, "We're—you're all going to wear gloves
and you're going to get out there and we're going to practice that."
And so I'm like
You know I've played in — I'm from Wisconisin
We play in the snow
We play in the rain
We play in anything
I'm like, "I'm going to show him that I'm good."
And you're trying to always  impress your coach as a rookie
And so I'm like, "Coach—"
We're walking off the practice field
"I just, uh, wanted to tell you—"
He's like, "What? What? Spit it out."
I'm like, "I don't—I don't need to wear the gloves.
I throw—you know, I'm good."
-Yeah, you're good.
-I'm good.
because I'm really good
and he's just like
"Ah shit Romo. You don't know an F-ing thing.
"Put the glove on. Don't talk to me."
- I love it
And I was like, "Ok. I'm going to wear a glove today."
-Yeah
I found out about this guy
I'm mean, I knew about him already
But [Jon] Gruden was the guy
2005, you became the starter?
Or was it six?
-Six
-It was six
So it was preseason of six
and we're sitting in the meeting in training camp
and Drew Bledsoe is the starter.
He's the Dallas Cowboys starter.
I mean Tony Romo
Ok, yeah. He's this journeyman from Eastern — you know
- Illinois
and yeah —
and Gruden comes in one day
and on the clicker he goes
"Let me just show you guys something. I want to show you the new
starting quarterback for the Dallas Cowboys."
I was like, "What is he talking about?"
And he goes, "This Tony Romo guy — I mean, watch —
we're going to watch some drives of Tony Romo."
And I was like, "Damn, this guy is kind of good."
- Really?
- And it was my first real knowledge of Tony the player
to really watch him on film and go, "Ok."
I learned—I learned from an Atlantic City
garbageman/bartender
He was a Cowboys fan.
He goes, "We got our new guy. It's Tony Romo."
And I was like, "This guy doesn't know anything."
And then you haunted my Eagles for like a decade,
which was fantastic.
They haunted me a few times too
The love affair
stronger owner/quarterback
Jerry for you or [Robert] Kraft for Tom [Brady]?
-Oof
-Cuz Jerry loves you
-Oh my gosh, loves you
- That's a battle
- That is a battle
Is it like a dad thing?
Is it a grandfather thing?
Like what's that relationship like?
Oh, it's be like a dad.
- Dad. Yeah.
Yeah, I mean, they're just—
I mean
You know when I wasn't playing in —
I think it was '16.
Right
And Dak [Prescott] was playing and our team was playing great
I swear Jerry was still slightly uncomfortable
that the team was winning all the time
-You could tell
-Yes
And to be — and he was so estatic.
He loved it , right?
But whenever he saw me — his heart like—
I could feel
that he had a little bit of reservation about, like,
he wanted to win the Super Bowl more than anything
-Yeah
-Yes
But he was just—
There was just a little bit of tornness in his
core that made me love him even more than I already did
Nobody—you know, coaches and everyone else
They just go on and they're just going to — you know
[Jason] Garrett has a team and he's got everybody
and so he's just going to—
here was no—I never felt like it was
tearing him up a little bit
Whereas with Jerry
It felt — I felt that from him and Gene Jones
that like — it just
it felt like it hurt him a little bit
And it wasn't that you had to pick me
Because we were playing so well you have to go with Dak
It was just the fact that he cared
enough to make you feel that way
made me just —
care about him on another level
almost like he was, you know, like your dad.
One guy that definitely knows the details is [ Bill] Belichick
You're going to have to sit with him
before the first game of the year
- Yeah
Are you prepared for your meeting with Belichick?
Can you — what is that like when you have to sit
there and ask that man questions in a closed room?
- Well I did it like 10 times last year
- Yeah
So we had like—I feel like we did
eight straight New England games to end the year
Yeah. Welcome to CBS.
- Was the first one scary?
The first one was a little bit
because when, you know, he walks in
you know, it's Belichick, so you already know
And sure enough he's got a suit
on that's four times too big
You know it's just—it's like—
- His style is absurd
He sits there and he's —
- He doesn't smile or anything. He just — yeah.
So we have the room and usually those other people
are a little intimidated
when you have a group of eight people or 10
and you're in—it's our environment,
almost, that you're coming into.
Belichick
He ain't intimidated at all.
He walks in and he's just — sits there and then —
[Jim] Nantz is like. "Do you want to go first, Tony?"
And I was like, "Nope. You're—you're going first."
- "You're the man."
- "Jim, go ahead."
So they—he's like, "Hey Coach."
Belichick's just like
And then he's like, "So what are you —
Think you guys—you're going to be pretty good this year.
Looks like you got a good squad and everything."
He's like,
"I'm trying."
That's it. You're right.
And so now are you sweating?
-I'm sitting here and then —
-"What's my follow up?"
And then he's like, "So what do you think about blah, blah, blah?
This team — they're really good in the red zone. How are you going to —"
Kind of that or something like that
And he's just like,
-It's really like that though.
-No words?
- No. He's just going to shrug —
Dude you're making me uncomfortable
That's how it is!
It's the most uncomfortable like 10 seconds
So then it comes to my turn to talk
and I'm like, "Oh gosh. I just don't want
to have the uncomfortable moments."
- Right, right
And so then I'm just like — you know
I have all these questions about football in general
I don't even care about his team
So then I just start talking about the Giants in the '80s
You bring stuff up and he goes down
history lane and that's when he opens up
- Yeah
Our favorite coach in the NFL, Kyle Shanahan, has
your Eastern Illinois guy: Jimmy Garoppolo
Is there a bond you, Sean Payton, Jimmy G —
I'm sure this is a thing but
when you look at him is there pride that like,
"Wow I didn't think there'd be a lot of us coming from this school."
And now you're got like a few of you guys in the league.
Yeah there's like a pride and there's like a weird competition
just underneath it all too. It's perfect.
Like Sean's always like, "Yeah, but you never broke my yards records."
I was like, "Yeah but I threw 1,000 more touchdowns than you."
It was —  it's always fun to do that
And Jimmy's such a good kid.
I don't know Jimmy that well. We've only talked a couple times.
But he's really nice and I know he's a
hard-working kid and everyone loves him back at Eastern.
- You know, me and Sean are pretty close.
- Yeah
He's like my Jon Gruden
Right. He's your first O.C.
- And I heard he wanted to trade for you
in New Orleans before they got [Drew] Brees
Yeah. He did. He tried for a little bit and —
You know, I'd still be playing if he did that but —
First he goes out and takes your dad's job
I mean, yeah, "Mister, mister. I have no more money.
My family. My dad's job is gone.
Do you have any money on you, mister?"
But wait, you stole his job and then —
Are you stealing my coach's job too?
I got Jon's
That's what you're doing now, huh?
-So you know what that means?
-I got to pay for my kids to eat too
I'm not playing anymore. I'm barely making ends meet.
Simms, so are you ready for it to become "Romo & Lefkoe"?
Yeah. That's next, huh?
Yeah
So  no but seriously we're going to take this chair out
Seriously?
No. Seriously.
Seriously. No you need to get out of here, seriously.
I'm top. I'm top on this one.
There he is. He's got you.
I feel like you and Corona, though, is perfect together.
I mean, who doesn't like a Corona?
Tastes good, right?
I mean, a lime with a Corona is just as good as it gets.
That's what I drink at his house
Yeah it's —
I turn it upside down, let the lime marinate in there
-Turn it over. Spray comes out a little.
-Pop some spray.
That's the Corona move
Thank you
You the man. Thanks for coming by, man.
-Thank you guys. Appreciate it, Chris. Thanks buddy.
Have an awesome year
Thanks, Adam.